bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
comme d'habitude on vous invite à nous
suivre sur les routes de la réunion à la
rencontre des agriculteurs qui ont
décidé d'ouvrir l'exploitation au
travers de ferme auberge
pour ce nouveau numéro c'est au mac que
je vous emmène où j'ai rendez vous avec
jean max nativel qui tient ici la ferme
auberge la fenêtre je sens et le
rejoindre sur son exploitation alors
sans perdre une minute c'est parti
apparemment jean max et déjà affairé on
va le rejoindre
comment ça va jean max ça va bien ça va
bien theben à l'appui à tomber à soit
pas tombé début d'e3 jaune avec ça ça va
ça va ça va mais on sait nous voilà le
ferme auberge de la fenêtre
voilà seul et donc du coup tu accueilles
les gens juste en bas tu as ferme
auberge
voilà alors à la fenêtre oui je peux que
comme une personne là bas
150 personnes on va dire et tout ce que
tu as et c'est là tout ce qui te propose
à ta table là bas en bas un tableau
d'autres finalement tout vient de cette
exploitation
oui en saison oui bon bah on va
commencer par nous verser à la gelée
monsieur
ils ont six kilos pour joueurs
actuellement c'est 3 kg le matin voire
kg le soir mais ces animaux là nous
libèrera zot dix mois 12 mois s'est
passé pas l'engagement de dire voilà six
et douze mois
dix à douze mois et parce que du
maraîchage qu'est ce que tu fais pousser
ici ici tous types ou et ses bas on a
des périodes où nous fait le chou chou
fleur brocoli la pomme de terre nous
fait deux fois l'année c'est à dire
commencer en septembre au niveau et
piste où poussent le temps le ps il les
oignons à tout tout pousse on peut tout
faire
à commencer par clément le petit bémol
pour apporter du piment cette année bon
mais c'est bon on a une éthique dans les
compliments et toute la tunisie qui a
une grosse partie son exploitation qui
est destiné aux fourrages en fait aux
vétérinaires les animaux voilà j'ai
préféré mettre de la can now lieu du
fourrage qui classé que parce que bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
richesses on voit mieux les animaux
pousser et au niveau rentabilité aussi
ses messages dans laquelle fourrage as
tu me disais qu'il y avait 10 12 mois
d'engagement la présence forte tête de
bétail ou à la belle on peut on peut
gagner quelques jeux au classement par
rapport à ça bon on va récupérer toit
pour manger ce midi alors ben c'est
mehdi on va récupérer un peu les pays
ainsi qu'aux pays touchés bah oui allez
c'est parti
à
comité a présenté aussi cela reste un
peu je suis ici pour ça jean max avec
grand plaisir
l homme a porté les pommes de terre oui
là quelques lapins en liberté ça fait
trois ans on les a mis en liberté ils
ont des petits coups d euros donc voilà
et à combien de superficie ont tous sur
l'exploitation la l'exploitation ici ben
on va dire 5 ha oui bon mais c'est vrai
nous on prévoit d'agrandir bientôt
peut-être d'avoir une dizaine des camps
je ne dirais pas de lâcher sa caméra et
venir planter des pommes de terre avec
moi et du coup tout ce que là tout ce
qui est planté comme les pommes de terre
par exemple c'est tout tout ça c'est des
produits qu'on va retrouver dans
l'assiette on va la table au dos une
partie où il aussi rappelé sur la mangue
mais c'est un travail pénible
il faut parfois après c'est aussi ça le
concept de la ferme auberge quoi c'est
dire que certes on accueille les gens un
certain la table d'hôte bientôt l'asp
exploitation à côté bénéteau alors voilà
ton poulailler ouais parce qu'on est
parti pour nous garder voilà à donner à
manger à la wii sur le problème ici bas
en ce moment peut-être que au niveau des
poules et peio de son peu près 200 en
liberté oui en liberté parce que je
retire hôtels et quelques copains en
cage
du coup toutes et tous l'assurent
liberté ils sont liberté tout en liberté
et bien voilà depuis le but étant jeune
et dans moscou dans les branches dans
les manches genou c'est pour ça qu'on
laisse un peu de végétation autour c'est
pas que mon bébé
ils peuvent dormir en haut ils sont
protégés pour voir les chiens la nuit
moment si le chien des attaques qui sont
en haut il ya ya ya pas de souci
l'échalas quoi d'autre comme comme
animal qui pourrait les manger la nuit
comment le pape en avant dans la nuit
par la nuit mais la journée comme il ya
six à la végétation ils peuvent se
camoufler un peu de sous c'est bon mais
sinon 6,6 être explosé mobile et papon
gobain un poulet d'un kilo acquis le
sens qu'ils vont ils vont aller cette
alerte est allé perdre comme ça chaque
année à cause des amis arrivent tout le
temps et ça c'est tous les poulets de la
même espèce est d'accord ça se touche
tous les pays
ça c'est le poulet pays c'est pour faire
des coqs de combat le shore là dedans ça
va peut-être dès que l'on rangé pour la
table d'hôte voilà n'est non seulement
pas seulement nous les coqs
les jeunes comme nous on quand ils sont
arrivés à cet âge et commence à se
bagarrer nous on va les mettre en cage
on va les essayer et si c'est bon ou god
on sélectionne pour avoir à faire des
combats est-ce que tu as un coq de
combat que tu pourrais me présenter la
champions
on a tous ces cons plaque millavois
exemple via voir exemple mais dali pays
et ça fait tomber à la vente six ans
après tout va bien tout dépend si c'est
un bon coach bomba les coqs de combat ça
peut aller de 200 euros jusqu'à 2000
on a vu ta vibrant cage autant avoir
cette bulle en l'amener à détroit comme
de chez basse et le poulet fermier
classique que nous fait de temps en
temps pas petites bonnes et ça c'est
uniquement pour la table pour tout
d'accord est obligé de les garder comme
ça séparé du reste est dû à huy obligé
sinon au pays vont les tuer ah oui
effectivement elle a commencé
petit club de décoration hors sujet il
est pas du tout fait pour manger il est
juste fait pour être jolie et ça marche
plutôt bien mais méchant il est méchant
hâtez-vous bataille ça va je vais pas te
piquer ton maïs
bon bah ça y est on a doublé le bétail
on a porté les pommes de terre
on a récupéré notre patte ce midi donc
du coup on descend à la table d'hôtes on
va rejoindre daniel la femme de jean max
pour préparer le cari et oui c'est le
toit dont je parle
et ouais là monsieur le club est en fait
la juge je tire dans les plaines seuls
les 50 ou sur la fin de compte c'est
qu'on a tenté au vert ici on a commencé
table d'hôte en 97 thème le doute
s'était limité à 25 ouvert l'époque et
comme nous on avait une demande un peu
plus importante nous on a décidé de
passer fait maubeuge et voilà à tester
moment pour répondre à la demande en
fait c'était pour répondre à la demande
pas dormi après c'est vrai que l'on a
deux chambres d'hôtes et une capacité de
huit places
thual crise les commandes du coup ben
nous on fait le poulet pinault fait
spécialement en train entre harry et le
kari traditionnels
alors c'est quoi ta version du cari
poulet à toi cari de poulet s'est fait
avec des oignons un petit peu d'ail peu
de thym un petit peu de thomas à toi tu
veux de tomates
ah oui parce qu'il ya des gars qui
disent que le charity le pape tomates le
rougail tu mets des tomates à l'eau dans
le car est folle et moi je mets tout
petit peu mais pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup même type et de tomates qui
s'enlacent au säntis peu après un petit
peu de safran tibet voilà safran safran
pays
bah oui une fois la une oui oui
on travaille en famille c'est à dire
avec notre fils notre belle fille la
plupart du temps où notre fils tant
entendu nous donne à coup de magie
allez après une matinée bien chargée à
la ferme comme à l'auberge
il est temps de passer à table on venu
on a un gratin chouchou inca et poulet
et en dessert un gâteau qui sont
maintenant il va encore monter dans le
joli oreilles pourtant après miracle ici
- lit vraiment très bien
voilà trop ringard
mon record et la morue chéri qu'elle
m
mais non
non
on a ça y est on vient de descendre de
kayes poule est délicieux et jean max a
décidé de m'emmener faire un petit tour
sur l'auteur des mac pour me faire
découvrir un coin qui connaît et qu'il
affectionne particulièrement
l'endroit où j'ai un peu grandi parce
que mes grands parents habitaient et ce
coin là s'appelle la plaine banner dans
un endroit isolé on peut y aller à pied
et bien jusqu'à présent y ait encore des
gens qui habitaient là bas on vient donc
de se poser dans une des nombreuses
aires de pique nique on peut trouver au
mac
à part ça qu'est ce qu'on peut voir ici
juste en haut il ya le point de vue la
fenêtre on a aussi l'observatoire
astronomique que nous on a mac aventure
ce qui est pas très loin il ya des
randonnées à faire il ya là du côté de
la vallée du bras de patates et à le
piton cabris à on peut aller même
jusqu'aux tapage en descendant pas en
passant par le piton cabris
il ya quand même pas mal de choses à
faire toi tu es au mac depuis toujours
c'est vrai que je suis né à l'étang salé
mais j'avais à peine un mois quand je
suis monté au maquis pour habiter du
muscle jusqu'à ce jour donc et tu
faisais quoi avant d'abord où martin tu
affirmes que je travaillais dans une
branche ou qui avait rien à voir avec le
secteur que je suis actuellement
pourquoi avoir choisi l'agriculture
c'est quoi cet avis de l'époque qui
convenait plus où c'était vraiment par
conviction et a décidé d'admettre que
l'élevage est tout bon mais comme j'aime
bien les animaux russie bon mais ça
c'était le c'était de trouver et on
croire tu aime bien les gens aussi à la
voix si c'est vrai c'est un métier qu'on
fait pas au niveau de l'activité
touristique
l'accueil touristique ont fait pas
d'accueil touristique si on n'aime pas
les gens c'est sûr aubin jean mach te
remercie pour cette journée je te
remercie pour un maroc fait découvrir
les maquettes en exploitation la vie
quotidienne ton travail de tous les
jours
pour moi c'était un plaisir jean max à
la prochaine
aucun but sur balles
m
là
et voilà c'est comme ça ex termine cet
épisode cette journée un passé au mac en
compagnie de jean max nativel alors vous
l'aurez compris si vous cherchez un
cadre magnifique et une bonne table vous
donne l'adresse et la ferme auberge la
fenêtre
en ce qui nous concerne on se retrouve
sur les routes de la réunion pour un
prochain épisode plus